[Music]
all right predictably after Sara Sanders
announced that John Brennan's security
clearance had been revoked
of course the destroyed Trump mainstream
liberal media of course extension of the
Democratic Party at a complete meltdown
let's take a look this is without
precedent
in in modern American history I mean
security clearances have never been used
to punish people for speaking out this
is nothing short of extraordinary and we
should all be scared about the state of
our democracy the president sent his
White House press secretary out there
today to basically poop on the people
from the press secretary podium and not
only threatened like they didn't just
make it threaded with the promise
they're snatching John Brennan's
national security clearance we begin
tonight with a chilling action taken by
the presidents of the United States that
looks something like something you might
see out of a dictate dictatorship or
authoritarian regime Trump is under fire
for Nick Sounion enemies list tactics
those are the accusations of at least
one former FBI official after the White
House is publicly admitting that it is
retaliating against former CIA director
John Brennan joining us now is the host
of ceará TVs Levin TV the host of life
liberty Levin Sunday night right here on
the Fox News Channel number one in his
slot I call on the great one Mark Levin
mark we have never had a former
communist who literally we now know
spread Russian lies to this inform
propagandize the American people to
impact in a presidential election either
these are unprecedented times see if we
can unravel this from the fabulously
stupid Omarosa media first of all
apparently the fact that Brennan voted
for a Stalinist who was funded by the
Soviets the Communist Party USA was very
attractive to Barack Obama who made him
CIA director think about that so how did
this man ever get a security clearance
I'm curious about this now a couple of
things the president is looking at
Brennan he revokes his security
clearance professor Dershowitz needs to
know that's a privilege that's not a
right of security
vilage the fact of the matter is nobody
stopping Brennan from speaking in fact
nobody could stop he has a big mouth he
will never shut up he'll go on TV and be
the kook that he is the idea that he has
a right to access the information
because he served in the Obama
administration at the CIA is a
preposterous argument but of course the
ACLU will take up the case because they
take up a lot of stupid cases that's
number one number two
who else is the president looking at
Comey and people who are keeping score
Comey is a Republican how many times in
the media told us Mahler's a Republican
Comey is a Republican and even they
questioned the president okay you got a
Republican and by the way for the media
most of these people the president are
looking at are white I know that's very
important to you know Comey was fired at
the recommendation of Rosenstein Comey
was a leaker and he absconded with
government documents when he left his
security clearance should be pulled
McCabe is under criminal investigation
the number two from the FBI never before
in history media his security clearance
should be pulled
Peter stroke was just fired the guy in
charge of counterintelligence
investigations for misconduct his
security should be pulled James clapper
committed perjury he lied to the
American people and Senator Wyden and
that committee a long time ago his
security clearance should have been
pulled Bruce or
another one pulled Yates another one not
because the president has a problem with
Democrats or liberals here's a problem
with these people and we haven't even
gotten to the unmasking issue yet so
this is not a First Amendment issue
meanwhile meanwhile when these people
had security clearances what the hell
did they do with them well let's take a
look the russians interfered in our
election right well who was president
who was head of the CIA who was national
security adviser who was the head of the
FBI all these people with their security
clearances in positions of power did
nothing effective to stop the Russians
from interfering in our election they
did nothing to stop China from stealing
our technology they did nothing to stop
North Korea's nuclear program and even
worse they awarded the aslam Oh
hold it mark the tourist regime that's a
rod with a hundred and fifty billion
dollars right with a hundred and fifty
billion dollars and provided them with a
pathway to nuclear weapons good job boys
and girls in the Obama administration
with your security clearances the fact
that Obama appointed these people and
gave them security clearances is not the
obligation of this president to let them
retain their security clearances there
is no constitutional issue that's just
nonsense
and again one of them's a Republican so
that makes this all okay mark I take
away all their clearances I take away
all their clearances too but the fact of
the matter is we really need to focus in
on the conduct of these individuals look
at the phony media and the arguments
they're making this is like a
dictatorship this is this is a we've
never seen anything like this before
all these blabbermouth who know nothing
you're gonna see clapper on TV till you
throw up on your loafers you're gonna
see Comey he had his book thing you're
gonna see Brennan all over the place all
these phony victims and so forth and so
meanwhile when they were in office when
they had their security clearances when
they had power they didn't stop the
Russians they didn't stop the Red
Chinese they didn't stop the North
Koreans they funded the Iranians and in
fact they are responsible for the
greatest scandal in American history by
interfering with our election and trying
to undermine the Trump campaign and the
Trump presidency and they are gonna
remember hold on mark and throw up on my
loafers but more importantly that's why
we call you the great one great
commentary Mark Levin thank you don't
forget Mark show Life Liberty Levin
every Sunday night 10:00 p.m. number one
in its timeslot right here on the Fox
News Channel